我谈了一个男朋友，
你帮我看看适不适合结婚。
我感觉男朋友干工作不够踏实，
我俩都在18线小城市，
家庭条件普通，
他有一份稳定的工作，
月收入5000，
但是他自己花钱大手大脚的，
属于月光族，
所以他总是想去挣一些快钱，
挣快钱的事儿也总想去投资。
而我是属于脚踏实地类型的，
他这样让我非常没有安全感，
他自己呢，
抽那个，
然后打量，
还喜欢去网吧，
去打游戏，
而且这个瘾还挺大。
但是他跟我说他结婚以后就不会这样了，
就会专心养家了。
我知道他在给我画饼，
你还挺清醒，
知道他在跟你画饼。
前段时间发现他和前女友联系，
视频能打两个小时，
他骗我说睡觉了，
其实是和前友在联系。
我之所以纠结犹豫，
是觉得他条件还可以，
我自己本身年纪也不小了，
圈子小，
可能也不太好找对象，
我俩是相亲认识的，
感情基础并不是很深厚啊。
王菲姐帮看看这男的合不合适结婚，
这种情况的话，
你还是要慎重吧，
他自己啊，
就是月入5000，
当然月入5000的话也不是说很差，
就是说在18线城市的话也算是正常的收入，
但是他自己花钱又大手大脚的，
他不说别的吧，
他光。
这个他一个月得花多少？
我问你，
你算算账吧，
他这个一天一包的话，
他一个月得花多少？
我就问一下直播间有多少人老公是这个的，
他光抽这个他得一个月得花多少？
一天是不是20挺正常，
他光这个的话就干掉小1000块钱，
然后他再去马长城东风发财，
白板他又给你干掉1000，
还去还上网打游戏，
他随便充个值，
他是不是又给你干钱，
给小装备啊，
买小皮肤啊，
小，
你指望他养家养孩子吗？
你指望他结了婚了之后他就改变他自己了吗？
这玩意儿可够呛，
再加上他跟他前女友还藕断丝连，
打视频打两个小时，
那表示什么？
李女生啊，
你说他条件还可以，
除非你跟我说什么呢？
他富二代非以你跟我说他妈妈跟向太性格差不多，
他妈妈跟你特别投缘，
他妈妈能够给你们买房买在你名下啊，
他妈妈能够一个月给生活费给你养孩子，
你要这么说的话啊，
也不是不可以，
但如果没有这样的公共流流，
不要冒这么大的风险了好吗？
你一算账你就能算明白吗？
他总共收入5000，
他又这个又这个东风白板发财来，
又完了之后又去打游戏，
又包宿又这那的，
他能剩个啥？
啊，
那养活自己就不错了，
他能不欠债就不错了，
完了他自己还有一点，
你不脚踏实地，
还老想挣块钱，
我跟你说怕就怕今天他懂个什么，
明天他要懂得这投资那投资的，
后天他又谈个这项目那项目的，
我告诉你就是个无底洞，
那因为他自己的认知水平支撑不了他在那些投资领域去挣钱，
那绝对我是借钱亏钱，
只有是到处各种网贷，
各种贷款，
然后亏钱，
你跟他过日子的话，
你什么时候才是个投入。